nous sommes dans la drôme au coeur des
montagnes à quelques kilomètres de
valence cet homme dans le 4 4 noir nous
a donné rendez vous sur une aire de
repos
perdu au milieu de nulle part je
l'espère 6 % mag bienvenus yves guillou
produire donc à la chasse landreau cuche
cet endroit au nom barbare est en fait
le premier village sans ombre de france
son directeur serge sargentini tient à
garder le lieu secret nous le suivons
donc sur une petite route de montagne
au bout de vingt minutes une grille des
panneaux d'avertissement
visiblement nous sommes arrivés mais
avant de rentrer nous devons nous plier
à une dernière formalité pour demander
de nous donner vos portables de les
arrêter
lui donner des merveilles mettre dans
une boîte si serge nous demande de nous
séparer de nos téléphones portables
c'est que dans cette zone tout ce qui
émet des ondes est considéré comme
dangereux
ceux qui viennent se réfugier ici se
disent elle est trop sensible
en clair les zones provoquerait chez eux
des réactions physiques plus ou moins
graves
un phénomène qui toucherait entre 3 et
6% de la population les gens donc qu'ils
viennent ici viennent surtout son état
de faiblesse donc sont fatigués ils
viennent se ressourcer
j'ai une zone donc sans rayonnement ou
très peu de rayonnement les rayonnements
dont parle serge ce sont les ondes
émises par les portables mais aussi le
wifi les lignes à haute tension ou
encore les fours à micro-ondes pour les
fuir au maximum il s'est fait prêter un
terrain isolé de tout parent à
particuliers sensibles à sa cause
ici tout est conçu pour se protéger des
ondes au maximum à commencer par ses
mobiles homes ou qu'on croirait sortis
d'un vieux film de science-fiction
chasser une caravane prototype de
programmation 100% cage de faraday et
les traiter bon c'est des coups c'est
toujours pareil c'est poussé à l'extrême
mais quand même une personne qui dort là
dedans qui arrivent fatigués une et les
dents c'est vraiment formidable
alors donc on retrouve le métal ya ici
vous avez des protections à 12 couches
en plus du métal
l'aluminium agit comme un bouclier anti
ondes indispensable pour les
électrosensibles car pendant la nuit les
zones perturberait la mélatonine
l'hormone régulatrice du sommeil est là
quand on dort là on dort comme un bébé
si on a un sommeil paradoxal fourmiz à
la visite continue avec ses douches
étonnante ancrée directement dans la
terre elle permet d'évacuer
l'électricité du corps vivement
conseillé aux nouveaux arrivants quand
vous êtes vraiment vous êtes chargé
complètement puis d'un coup vider les jt
c'est un ressourcement mon dos est dopé
qu'on voit là ça peut paraître
surprenant pourtant ça a l'air de
marcher quand il est exposé aux ondes
philippe est sujet à d'affreuses
migraines cet habitué des lieux n'arrive
jamais ici sont passés sous la fameuse
touche au but de cette lutte de suisse
peut se redisant que peut avoir ce petit
dans la tête et que tous ces leviers
pour augmenter son personnel pour les
centristes pour il faut les pieds un
certain temps mais après on est bien en
amont si serge a ouvert ce dieu unique
en europe ce n'est pas par hasard il ya
quelques années il a lui même commencé à
ressentir les effets de ces ondes
électromagnétiques migraines à
répétition mêmes troubles digestifs
pour lui il n'y a pas de mystère car
pendant des années il a vécu à proximité
d'une antenne relais comme celle ci
voilà l'antenne relais classique que
vous connaissez nous envoient des
demandes et hyperfréquence micro ondes
ça n'existait pas il ya 15 ans si ce qui
est à l'origine de cette nouvelle
commission environnement
non par contre resté bien longtemps là
c'est une zone qui nous perturbe
beaucoup leurs airs le fil rouge des
picotements au bout de seulement 5
minutes au pied de l'antenne relais
les symptômes réapparaissent ce mal dont
souffrent ces rejet des autres est
heureusement très rares son nom le
syndrome e hs pour
électro-hypersensibilité reconnu dans de
nombreux pays européens et même par l'om
est il est carrément considérée comme
une maladie en tuer nous en angleterre
pourtant en france on reste sceptique
le professeur belpomme cancérologue
réputé est l'un des premiers à s'être
interrogé sur le phénomène
les uns donnent ce syndrome sont au
début des maux de tête des acouphènes
c'est à dire des impressions de bruits
bizarres dans les oreilles sifflements
bourdonnements des troubles de
l'attention et la concentration des
troubles de la mémoire avec un déficit
de la mémoire immédiate
ils sont fatigués en fin de journée ou
même le matin au réveil la le sommet
n'ayant pas été réparateur si le
syndrome le hs n'est pas reconnue chez
nous les études sont formelles les
symptômes eux sont bien réels maux de
tête picotements acouphènes
ici tout le monde sait de quoi on parle
des visiteurs viennent d'ailleurs de
toute l'europe pour profiter de cette
zone anti ondes
philippe lui n'est que de passage pour
fuir les ondes cet ancien instituteur à
trouver encore plus fort moi mon
principal filtre ce sont les montagnes
qu'environ je vis dans des endroits
complètement isolé le jour de notre
visite nous avons aussi rencontré un
alban nikkei
ancien ingénieur télécoms le comble pour
un ami trop sensible
quant à isabelle mariée et mère de
famille
tiens ici pour la première fois et
contrairement aux apparences elle n'a
pas l'intention de jouer les
agricultrices
alors ce voile c'est un tissu de
blindage anti-ondes c'est un maillage de
fils métalliques et du fil d'argent et
de cuivre qui est comme une cote de
maille très fine
il est le maillage fait 0,6 mm de côté
et ça empêche le passage des ondes
après une première nuit dans la fameuse
caravane c'est électrosensibles se sent
comme l'oeuvre
écoutez j'ai passé ma première nuit
cette nuit là sur le 6 et j'ai
parfaitement bien dormir à écouter ces
vacanciers d'un nouveau genre les
symptômes disparaissent comme par
miracle c'est leur arrivée mais la zone
anti ondes est elle vraiment protégé à
quelques kilomètres d'une antenne relais
est pas si loin des villes les
précautions de serge sont elles
suffisantes pour en avoir le coeur net
nous lui avons demandé de mesurer la
quantité dont par mètre carré à quelques
pas de l'antenne relais de tout à
l'heure
rapport à la zone rouge on compare à
tout à l'heure surtout voilà donc vous
avez actuellement ici 1,9 volt mais nous
avons ensuite fait la même expérience en
plein milieu du refuge en nous avons 020
m alors maintenant il ya forcément un
chiffre derrière un centième michael
vale mesurer avec un appareil qui est
beaucoup plus sensible il va vous donner
donc centièmes le chiffre qui est
derrière la hauteur râle quand m
résultat 100 fois moins que soul
antennes relais une différence bien réel
pour autant peut-on affirmer que les
ondes sont responsables de tous ces
symptômes
les études démontrent déjà une relation
existante ce qui ce qui est encore si
vous voulez l'objet des recherches
c'est la confirmation de ce lien et est
évident qu'il faut en france comme on
l'a fait ailleurs pour le tabagisme
faire en sorte qu' il ait des zones sans
champs électromagnétiques des zones
blanches pour que ces malades puissent
se retrouver même s'ils ne sont pas
encore reconnus grâce à serge les
électrosensibles sa fondement ou passer
leurs vacances - des ombres
[Musique]